Margot Robbie certainly didn't suffer the
agony of "defeat" to pull off this shot.
But how did it come together in the
first place? Movie trickery is afoot.
Are you wondering exactly how Margot Robbie pulled
off that shot in the "Barbie" trailer where she
steps out of her heel onto a perfectly arched
foot? Apparently, a lot of people were — so Robbie
ended up having to address the whole shebang while
promoting her upcoming film. How many takes was
it? Was the shot created using movie magic? Did
Robbie actually do it? Not that many, no, and yes.
As Robbie revealed in a behind-the-scenes
interview with Fandango,
"It was probably about eight takes. Wasn't that
many. They are my feet. I walked up, we had little
sticky bits on the floor for the double sided
tape for the shoes, so they wouldn't come off,
so that I could get my feet out of them. And I was
holding onto a bar, but that's it. I wasn't in a
harness or anything like that. I just walked
up, kind of held onto the bar above camera."
Asked if she was a dancer based
on her high arch, Robbie said,
"I did ballet when I was a kid."
But still, her point was that she
wanted to do the shot herself:
"I always try and do my own inserts.
I don't like when I watch a movie and
I know it's not my hands. I hate that
so much. I always say to the director,
'please let me do all my own things.' I
don't like knowing that I didn't do it."
If you're anyone who ever
played with Barbies as a kid,
you know exactly why this shot was so vital
to the trailer and the overall film. Those
who have played with a Barbie know that her
plastic foot is always perfectly arched,
ready to slip into whichever pair of
shoes you decide to choose next — and
the journey Robbie's Barbie takes in the movie
is revealed through her lack of a sharp arch.
When Barbie's foot goes flat,
she shows her Barbie friends,
only to receive a horrified reaction as
they realize she's less than perfect. Other
strange happenings are going on too — her
clothes don't dress her on their own anymore,
she can't float off her roof without falling
and injuring herself, and she can't stop
thinking about dying. Perplexed, Barbie visits
Weird Barbie, a Barbie erratically styled by
her owners and played by Kate McKinnon,
who presents... a shoe-related conundrum.
"You have to go to the real world."
You might look at Margot Robbie and think,
"yeah, that's what Barbie looks like," and
you probably wouldn't be alone —
in a Time feature about the film,
Mattel executives basically stop short of
saying exactly that. Robbie, for her part,
was smart enough to know that this movie
needs to be more than a close look at how
Barbie is blonde and beautiful — and along with
writer-director Greta Gerwig, she made sure that
the film features a diverse array of actors
playing Barbies. Robbie told the magazine,
"If [Mattel] hadn't made that change to have a
multiplicity of Barbies, I don't think I would
have wanted to attempt to make a Barbie film.
I don't think you should say, 'This is the one
version of what Barbie is, and that's what women
should aspire to be and look like and act like.'"
"Insecure" star and creator Issa Rae,
who plays President Barbie in the film,
clearly agrees; in the same feature, she said
"My worry was that it was going to feel
too white feminist-y, but I think that
it's self-aware. Barbie Land is perfect, right?
It represents perfection. So if perfection is
just a bunch of white Barbies, I don't know
that anybody can get on board with that."
Not only did Robbie and Gerwig craft an inclusive
and diverse world full of Barbies all crushing
it in their own right, but, by their own account,
they worked together to create a fun, subversive,
and clever film even though it's centered
around a toy and overseen by a toy company.
They still ran into some problems when it came
to the Mattel overlords, though. According
to the Time article, Robbie and Gerwig had to
perform one scene live for President and COO of
Mattel Richard Dickson, who objected to... well,
whatever happens in it, because we still don't
know. Performing it in person worked, though, and
he agreed to keep the scene. Robbie clarified,
"When you look on the page, the nuance
isn't there, the delivery isn't there."
Ultimately, it's about being in
on the joke... and apparently,
that's a concept Robbie had to
explain to Mattel's CEO Ynon Kreiz.
"In that very first meeting, we impressed upon
Ynon we are going to honor the legacy of your
brand, but if we don't acknowledge
certain things—if we don't say it,
someone else is going to say it. So you might
as well be a part of that conversation."
Robbie definitely took charge of the
"Barbie" movie — and as a result,
it looks amazing, including that
iconic foot shot performed by the
Oscar nominee herself. "Barbie"
hits theaters on July 21, 2023.